okay so iido is mind and body
coordination so you can't you can
because you're doing it but if you just
do this then it means that you split up
any understanding about sediment and
that inside your body if you
[Music]
go
hey so the third Super he should have
the
longest key eye I'll do it for you I
just breathe out nowadays
but okay
so how quick can I become calm after
that so it's all a process of
learning um oh yeah you have it it's all
about
eica you
know it's all about etica that's why I
like it I think it's a martial art for
perfectionists because if you're
perfectionist you'll never perfect
anything cuz you'll always want it a
little bit better so iido is a wonderful
art for perfectionists I I personally
believe because we're always trying to
be
self-critical second
subur first
subur second
subur third
subur fourth subur is quite easy it's
the first you pull the foot back second
pull the foot
back
this shaking was designed in ama for
ladies because CTO Sensei said that the
ladies were sort of like doing that and
they weren't showing any power in their
Ken Cuts they were just sort of like
coming to a stop and it was a a weak
stop so he said look get there and shake
the salt out and they started getting
more powerful and so he said we're going
to do that with the men as
well so I went for a lot of boring
stages with cyto Sensi but after about
three
months
hey you start to think oh yeah that
actually adds to it so right
so first
subur second subur this is a very
difficult subury to do because the hips
have to keep straight not turned
so it's a very difficult one so we used
to think about there's a big log here
and there's a blade up there and a
sawmill and we've got to push this
log like that in a straight line so we
got to push this log in a straight line
we mustn't do this and push it
downwards lot of people get confused
when they say use the hips what they
really mean in the one when is you use
the
pelvis you don't
turn the hips you use it's a pelvic
twist and the problem is the higher you
get the less I mean I'm exaggerating for
you people but it gets less C sensey
would be
here it be in line with these Solas is
it s
plexus he'd be there and we'd all start
copying him you see and he start
shouting at him saying what you doing
you've got to be down here near your
Naval so he'd show you once then he go
back
to but that was cuz he was a night then
you know so you need to go here to
parallel
okay do your
best remember do your best for yourself
not for
me so we got the fourth
suburi